okay  good afternoon i had a constructive and  useful phone call with prime minister  boris johnson  we discussed the major unsolved topics  our negotiation teams have been working  day and night over the recent days  and despite the exhaustion after  almost one year of negotiations and  despite the fact that deadlines have  been missed over and over  we both think that it is responsible at  this point in time  to go the extra mile we have accordingly  mandated our negotiators to continue the  talks  and to see whether norwegian an  agreement can be reached  even at this late stage  the negotiations continue here in  brussels  thank you so much  [Music]  you